in the previous videos you could see us
cleaning a waterfall it was cleaned but
still quite rough
it was a bigger job than expected
but already great to use
however summer is here
things changed and the neighbor told us
the best part is still to be discovered
now we are going back to find out what
that is
welcome to a new project camp update
today we are starting early so we get
some fresh hours before the sun starts
to burn still lots of brambles some dead
trees to take away and bushes that make
it difficult to move around the
different areas of the waterfall
with the extreme heat of this summer the
waterfall has dried quite a lot
now we have left a small stream of water
that is not enough to gather under and
refresh even not enough to keep the
water flowing through the small ponds so
leaves are rotting on the surface and
algae and mud have taken the water so
it's not cool to dive in anymore as our
neighbor tanekas told us the best part
is not on the bottom but on the top
behind the wall of cane on the upper
side there used to be a lagoon
compartment
so in this video we're gonna clean it
all the way up to see if we can find it
it's gonna be some hard working days a
lot of sun but we can count on some
friends
hello my name is emma and i'm 30 years
old i'm from the netherlands and i'm a
woodworker
i left my home a couple of months ago
and now i'm traveling with my boyfriend
through portugal
we are doing some workaways because the
both of us want to live in a
self-sustaining community somewhere
around here i like to be outside and
have a big interest in flora fauna and
wildlife
now we are at project camp to use our
own skills i brought all my machines
with me and a good amount of energy so
enjoy
hi i'm emmanuelle but everybody calls me
hema i'm an architect but i was a
photographer from varese north of italy
i'm here for a month drawing general
maps and doing architectural survey for
project scam master plan but i'm also
helping with manual work in the
maintenance of the land i needed to
question my way of living and that's why
i came here every day i like to learn
new things from the nice people that i'm
meeting and facing new challenges that
push me to become a better human
ok so the team is ready hopefully with
some help from the camp we can
accomplish a goal as soon as possible
we're not sure i was gonna go but let's
see
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so today will be all about chopping
bushes taking the rumbles out cutting
the cane on the top we will clean up
first the rough areas then we go into
the details and make it all nice and
tidy and offset i think we just need to
start and make it happen so let's go
[Music]
so
[Music]
look we found the bug
[Music]
destroyed his home
[Music]
it's so sad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're coming
[Music]
so i was trying to reach the
the water from from above but i can see
it now and
it's not a lot
and i can see the gate over there and i
will try to keep all that
up and bring it up
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
last one
last one of this genre
right as you can see we have been
cleaning the
cane away
you can see the door from the back now
but we also can see that there is
actually no water in the lagoon almost
nothing it's very dry these months so
this gives us the opportunity to clean
everything out
get it tidy and then we try to make this
door functioning again so we can close
it and the water will fill up that's
what we're gonna try
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
so
oh there's a julie in the dark
[Music]
julie in the dark
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on come on
oh that was close
exhausted but happy
i just really want to eat
ted's dishes
[Music]
so the door is cleared out
now we need it to move
because it's all rusted and yeah i'm
trying to take the rust out and
try to move it
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
nice
[Music]
right now is
completely stuck
in between these bars
so
let's see i am trying some
some stuff
and see what's what's working if it is
[Music]
[Music]
what is branding
at the door
[Music]
so
[Music]
how are we doing
but
it's frustrating because
we tried a lot of instruments a lot of
i don't know tools but
actually it didn't mean didn't do the
nothing
and yeah the door is still
blocked
still sealed
thanks to the rust that
is built between those
spaces
and
we don't have any more ideas other than
take it out and bring it to the base cup
so it's time to cut the tree
if that one over here burned down in
2017 and the big fire and there are some
young trees growing around that we want
to give space so dave is doing his
sketchy tricks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i thought i think the light part
[Music]
possible
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yeah with the water it's really clean
and there's like this big
very big frog sitting over there
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
here's the end result
the lagoon is empty let me show you the
rest here used to be a big granite wall
as you see but it has collapsed a part
of it maybe in the future we will build
this back up but for now we leave it
like this this is the metal door still
in the same position unfortunately we
couldn't get it moving but it's part of
our irrigation system also found two
pipes in the bottom of the lagoon they
might be to relieve the pressure when
the lagoon is completely filled with
water but we're not really sure
so here we found another pipe
with something like a valve or something
to close and open the water because it
could stream in this channel from the
pump it will flow here in the canal and
distribute the water to the other side
of the land so here you still see some
grooves for a wooden panel which would
make it able to direct the water
you could close it then the water would
continue you could open it and the water
would flow down this big flat rock is
also a really nice feature of the land
good place to play some cars have a
picnic and imagine that next to a lagoon
quite awesome
and here we are at the left top of the
waterfall
there's a nice areas with a lot of
native trees we clean them up so they
have some space to grow and hopefully in
the future they will give us enough
shade
finally we are at the down part at the
waterfall the most exciting part of the
whole area
at the moment is not as exciting because
there's not much water because of the
growth but hopefully in winter we get
much more rain and fills up and we can
swim again but until winter comes we can
have lunch here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you